bon c'est pas un moment quand vous a pas
vu à la télé je sais pas peut-être mais
si vous étiez dans l'armée israélienne
voilà ça c'était quelle émission ça
c'est la première compagnie en plus
sérieux c'est cette expérience que vous
racontez arnaud à yves derai qui est
journaliste nouvel économiste et à
l'optimum
dans un livre intitulé israël transit
qui est publiée à l'archipel
alors dans l'avant propos il devrait
expliquer sa perception à lui d'arno
klarsfeld le côté agaçant ados attardés
fils à papa playboy provocateur qui
arrive à rollers au procès papon mais
aussi le mec qui à 20 ans se rend seul
un meeting du front national monte à la
tribune et traite le pen de raciste
devant 5000 supporters quoi je le mec
qui lors de la visite du pape à vienne
se déguise en officier nazi et pour
symboliser le passé du président
autrichien caudeval dindon il raconte
également l'irritation grandissante que
vous aviez devant le traitement du
conflit du moyen-orient dans les médias
français
et c'est ce qui a motivé d'ailleurs
votre départ de l'émission ne peut pas
plaire à tout le monde où je crois vous
êtes resté coi une semaine non j'ai fait
une émission pourquoi vous êtes parti
bon je sais pas j'étais là l'émission
ils m'ont dit je m'en veux plus c'était
en 2001 si c'était 7,70 ces quelques
jours avant le 11 septembre
il m'avait dit avant vient traiter un
billet d'humeur
vadis que tu penses et
saoulé déprendre dire ce que je pensais
sur israël c'est à dire que je pensais
que les israéliens voulaient la paix que
la pme était tout à fait atteignable que
il valait mieux avoir des démocratie au
moyen-orient que des dictatures qu'il
n'y a eu jamais eu de guerre entre les
démocraties est que plus les régimes
sont démocratiques plus la paix est
possible
donc j'ai critiqué les saddam hussein
j'ai critiqué kadhafi j'ai dû critiqué
assad et ça a suscité des réactions soit
disant indignée de la part de
téléspectateurs et ce qu'ils ont voulu
transiger en disant que avoir un droit
de réponse et puis moi je me taise et
que je peux en passer un autre sujet
donc ça m'a pas ça m'a pas plu donc j'ai
dit voilà donc c'est là que vous êtes
devenu d'abord citoyen et serait bien et
puis ensuite que vous avez décidé de
vous engager dans l'armée israélienne
alors au départ vous êtes dans une unité
de relations avec la presse c'est plutôt
une semaine ouais toujours une semaine
j'avais fait virer rapidement n'ont su
rester une semaine et puis ça c'était
dans les bureaux donc ça me convenait
pas donc j'ai dû demander un peu à
droite à gauche et finalement je suis
allé au dans les gardes frontière à
frontière de bethléem 1m à gaz ils font
pas l'unanimité en israël 1 cela les
maga venons ils sont assez ils ont la
réputation d'être assez dur c'est eux
qui sont qu'il faut qu'ils procèdent au
contrôle mais c'est aussi eux qui
qui saute quand il ya des camps et des
kamikazes qui sont la dernière barrière
de sécurité donc
il ya du positif et du négatif alors
entraînement très difficile quand on est
la description de ce que l'iphone se
mettait à genoux tirer se relever et se
mettre à genoux la fin ne restent pas ne
s'était pas et c'est pas une unité des
geeks non plus c'est pas un entraînement
très il ya faut courir 1 2 mm faut pour
faut faire des tractions des pompes et
des exercices de tir en courant avec
hommes mais avec le le harnais et par
balles arnaud vous êtes jamais dit
qu'est ce que je fous là quoi tu peux
être au flore avec une super man qui
n'est tout qu'est ce que je fous là
m'ont gardé dans le sable en train de
crapahuter dans le parcours du
combattant
bah quand on est actif on se dit pas ce
genre de trucs et puis si on veut
quelque chose il vaut mieux il vaut
mieux aller au bout et je crois qu'un
engagement ce nécessite aussi des
sacrifices c'est pour ça que j'étais
allé au meeting aussi ni front national
sachant très bien que il avait pas me
lancer des fleurs tient qu'à un moment
plutôt que de pérorer en france vous
êtes dit je vais y aller je vais sur le
terrain c'était être en accord avec
moi-même et en plus sur le terrain on
sent beaucoup plus vont se rendre compte
de la situation c'est à dire on ressent
plus les choses aussi alors vous
raconter effectivement la vie de ses
gardes-frontières j'ai appris un truc en
lisant votre bouquin c'est des âmes
piégé ça je connaissais pas à un moment
il y en a sur la vie laurent
ces pratiques commencé alors normalement
ils ont commencé après il ya eu des ânes
qui ont été piégés c'est à dire ils ont
bien une sacoche ceinture explosive dans
l'année l'âne s'est approché la
n'annonce pas gentil pour l'heure c'est
vrai les ricains et concert avec des
dauphins aussi s'est passé pour les
dauphins vous raconter les intrusions
dans l'est dans les chambres des
palestiniens la nuit l'humiliation
ressentie par les par les enfants quand
ils voient leur père se faire battre
c'est à dire par exemple quand on devait
contrôler par mme des puces va prendre
dans les bus et on voit des femmes avec
leurs enfants il faut regarder les
papiers d'identité tout ça c'est que ces
horribles comme tout comme chose à faire
enfin c'est pas pour moi c'est c'est
vraiment pas agréable
ou alors il ya des ambulances qui passe
on arrête l'ambulance on rentrait il
dame qui a longé il ya son mari à côté
et il faut regarder en dessous tout ça
mais s'il n'y avait pas eu de deux
ceintures explosives qui était passé
dans les ambulances
il y aurait pas ça non c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre c'est sa kippa feux qui
ont fait pas comprendre en france c'est
à dire que s'il n'y avait pas assez d
anne n'avait pas été piégé en tireraient
pas sur la guérir les gens sont obligés
de se protéger aussi et les contrôles si
les pas de contours ya eu 120 attentat
suicide
en l'espace de 90 à 120 ou 130
quand vous voyez vous voyez vous venez
tous les films avec les tueurs en série
tous les mesures de sécurité quand on
peut sont que ceux qui sont prises quand
quelqu'un un tueur en série dans les
parages cela c'est 120 qui ont quitté
dallas d'un coup dix personnes 15
personnes est la france est en 95 j'ai
eu deux premières des tentes a eu un
enfant 195,8 de saint michel
ouais ça michel est elle dans le train
là c'est 120 attentat suicide dans un
pays qui est tout petit seillier des
mesures sécurité qui sont indispensables
essayez pas de contrôle y aurait des
bombes ailleurs des bons tous les jours
alors raconter des trucs incroyables
comment un moment des habitants des
kibboutz envisage de prendre des cochons
comme chien de garde parce que le coach
en est avec ces l'ancienne gare
simplement en israël les cochons ne
peuvent pas marcher sur le sol
ils sont élevées sur les planchers
surélevés j'ai pas fait la ferme
et puis avait aussi cette idée qu'ils
ont eue d'enduire de graisse de porc les
bus de jérusalem c'est pour que les
kamikazes puisse passe se prenait
aussitôt il ya eu enfin une fatwa qui a
été lancée comme quoi si un kamikaze
faisait sauter au milieu d'enfants dans
un bus et et par malheur des bouts de
son corps avait touché la graisse de
porc se serait pas grave les ports du
peu du paradis lui serait toujours
ouverte parce que la la
la beauté de l'acte justifier le fait
que tout fin qui toucha du port on peut
avoir des laissez-passer quoi selon
certains ont parlé des attentats suicide
les femmes kamikazes pour vous
dites-vous aucune oppression ne justifie
cela il ya des peuples qui souffrent
beaucoup plus que ça et qui finalement
ne se font pas sauter quoi pour vous
c'est plus dû finalement à la propagande
et pas les attentats suicide avant que
l'autorité palestienne s'installe et
d'un à la bastide avec la propagande
s'installe donc ça vient ça vient
uniquement de la propagande sinon c'est
pas les gens veulent pas veulent veulent
passer par ses désespoirs de leur
situation
non vous raconter un attentat à tel-aviv
au mikes barre je suis passé
je suis passé devant et quand je passais
devant ça a sauté bon juste les jeux
projetée à terre enfin c'était moi j'ai
ri mais c'était pour les gens voit les
gens sortir s'embrassant sans ça je
crois que vraiment les européens ou ne
veulent pas se rendre compte de la
situation dans laquelle sont sont les
italiens je ressens de la compassion
pour les six plaignants je pense qu'ils
sont ils ont le droit à un état
mais israël a quand même aussi le droit
de se défendre
c'est ça que j'ai et les deux peuples se
dire c'est vraiment ça pourrait être un
paradis jerusalem un moment était
totalement vide
alors ça devrait être un paradis pour à
la fois pour les arabes pour les pour
lier pour les chiffres
alors pour vous le mur de sécurité a
aidé à ce qui est moins d'attentats le
le mur qu'on appelle le mur de la honte
il ya quand même trois cent mille
palestiniens qui se retrouvent entre la
frontière et le mur quoi c
évidemment que c'est catastrophique pour
certains c'est évidemment qu'il y en a
qui ressentent qu'ils doivent passer des
checkpoints où ils sont contrôlés n'est
encore une fois s'il n'est pas les
contrôler ça ce serait tout le temps et
il ya des innocents qui payent pas ce
que d'autres font passer des bons c'est
ça qui est qui et là où est ce que ce
que j'aurais du mal à comprendre ici en
tous les cas c'est que d'un côté sharon
prend des risques terribles il risque sa
vie pour libérer la bande de gaza et
parallèlement il ya des implantations on
peut dire décolonisation qui continue en
cisjordanie donc on a l'impression des
fois ici que le gaz à sa main leur qu'on
agite comme ça devant les médias et
pendant ce temps là on comptera lui
auront construit des logements
construits l'université ont construit
des on s'y joue mal et malades ou mines
qui est à deux stations de métro ça
aussi les distances les gens n'ont pas
conscience des distances non plus et à
quelques centaines de mètres quand le
jour où les palestiniens ou les leaders
palestiniens à dire ont écouté ce que
nous voulons nous voulons le très tard
nous voulons gaza nous voulons toute la
cisjordanie et nous voulons jérusalem
comme capitale et nous renonçons à un
droit de retour qui ferait des juifs à
une minorité
tout de suite la peine et la paix pas
compliquer la paix peut être conclu en
quelques minutes et les palestiniens qui
habitait là en 48 qu'est ce que il ya
vraiment jamais chez eux c'est d'accord
les palestiniens et des juifs les juifs
parents qui était qui et elle a enquêté
dans les pays arabes y avait un million
ou 900 milles qui était dans les pays où
ils n'ont plus reviendront pas juif
était à bagdad depuis je parle depuis ce
7ème siècle avant jésus-christ il
revient dans pas non plus et les
allemands qui étaient dans lé sud est
c'est très difficile de faire des juifs
une minorité en israël quoi oublier pas
il n'y a pas en israël un juif israélien
qui accepterait ça vous finissez les
entretiens avec yves derai sur
l'histoire des chocs j'aime bien aller
plein de change et aux élèves
bien jérusalem-est et jérusalem ouest je
suis du côté juif et celle du potet les
deux son trait d'union et j'ai trouvé
douche de chat vers la fin du service et
à jérusalem ouais c'est un qui s'appelle
roumi et l'autre qui s'appelle malka
s'il me regarde entre une belle histoire
que j'arrêterai oui mais j'arrive pas à
la raconter s'était écrié 1730 hockey
chaque corps de chats défend son
territoire et sa poubelle contre les les
autres corps qu'elle considère comme une
intruse pourtant dans l'absolu nul ni
intrus chaque chat afin echakhch ac doit
nourrir ses chatons chaque chat raison
et chaque chat à tort quiconque assiste
triste spectacle d'une bataille de chats
observera que lorsqu'aucune des corses
ne prend un ascendant déterminant des
règles de conduite sont silencieusement
entendue et respectée
si même les chats parviennent à des
compromis peut être existe t il un
espoir
[Musique]
il dresse est publiée à l'archipel et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
leonard itunes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus